a similarly devastating outcome from an
outbreak of leprosy the government sent
lepers into isolation on the island of
Molokai John tainment tells the story of
the Exile in his new book the colony
this is an hour now that we've got a
house keeping stuff out of the way I can
introduce tonight's guest I'm John
Taemin as you all know I'm sure is
current editor at Men's Health magazine
and former deputy editor of outside
magazine one of my favorites
he's also the author of the colony when
I was reading this book I had one of
those aha moments when I realized that
yet again my high school teacher history
teacher had let me down horribly you
know I'm sure that we've all had these
moments where we learn about instances
in our history that we've never heard of
before and were shocked not only because
they're particularly interesting and
sometimes more than a little sorted but
also because they're just they've been
completely off of our radar and I think
that's one of the reasons that we're
really fortunate to have writers like
John I mean he's taken the time to
research a very interesting issue it's
an excellent job researching it and even
better job writing about it if you
haven't read it yet it's a fascinating
read and you're definitely going to
enjoy it so I'm gonna let him read a
little bit of his book to you so please
join me in welcoming John thank you
everybody for coming out this is my
second reading so you have to bear with
me I did one last night and and learned
that they're sort of miss named because
apparently I read too long and didn't
talk enough so they should be author
talks I'll try and make it that way
instead I'm gonna tell you a little bit
about the general story and then read a
short passage I got interested in the
story as she said when I was at outside
and the magazine made a specialty for
awhile of survival stories and and I
began hearing about this and quickly
realized that this is probably the
greatest survival story in American
history and nobody had written about it
in 1866 the Hawaiian government
criminalized the disease leprosy they
did so because they thought it was
rampantly contagious and that it was
getting ready to decimate their own
population as it happens leprosy is
virtual
is very very difficult to catch it's one
of the least infectious diseases known
to man and 95% of the population has a
natural immunity to it they found all of
that out entirely too late
starting in 1866 until 1969 they exiled
more than 8,000 people to this island
prison and more than half of them didn't
have to go they were either misdiagnosed
found with simple things like sunburn or
psoriasis or eczema and mistakenly sent
away or they had a form of the disease
that wasn't contagious the 8,000 or so
that went almost all died there I spent
a year and a half
reporting the archives in Hawaii and
doing interviews with some of the
current residents and when I came back I
wrote the book here in San Francisco and
I had with me about 10,000 pages of
original material and I sat there trying
to figure out what to make of all of
this this is my first book so it was
sort of a learning process and I found
myself sort of getting sidetracked all
the time I remember one day I sent my
office and wrote three thousand words on
poi I figured it was important for
people to know about boy what the
consistency is and the nutritional value
and you know how it's made and and so I
was happily writing away and it was very
dramatic account of how to make POI
and I came home and it was very pleased
with myself and I my girlfriend asked
what I wrote that day and I told her
wait six pages about poi and it's
wonderful uh and she said well what's
that got to do with anything
and I realized that actually it didn't
really have anything to do with anything
and the next day I came in and I wrote
on the chalkboard above my desk what
happens next
which was all I used to write the rest
of the book and so the book just tracks
a straight chronology and it follows the
first patient all the way to the last
twenty-seven who were still there in the
first year of exile 142 people were
captured the government sent out doctors
agents and tax collectors more than
anybody else simply because they had
more tax collectors than any other
government agency and they would go out
and they would apprehend everybody they
suspected him had
the disease they brought them to a
central location ha Lulu and then every
couple of weeks they would March them to
the waterfront and put them in cattle
stalls on top of inter-island steamers
ship them 58 miles from Honolulu and
essentially marooned them in this prison
the first group of patients arrived
there are a hundred and forty years ago
this month and they were twelve men
there are 12 patients nine men three
women and this is what happened to the
next I'm gonna read a quick intro to
give you a physical description of and
then go and do another one it was one
observer remarked an almost Island
defined by a soaring curtain of stone
that ran the length of the northern
coast of Molokai at the foot of this
impassable wall the tallest Sikh lifts
in the world emerged a two-mile wide
triangle of earth sunburnt and dust
covered as a rider reported that year
blackened at the edges where the rough
flabber rocks were uncovered and froth
from end to end with tumbling breakers
with no landing site along the
peninsula's rocky shore the vessels
arriving at the colony had two choices
if the sea was calm the captain could
anchor a half mile offshore of kala Wow
and using a whale boat horsemen would
try to ferry cargo to a narrow beach of
rock at the mouth of the valley east of
the peninsula surf was treacherous along
the stretch and whale boats were often
up ended or swamped cast adrift
passengers might be hoisted on waves to
the stony beach but they could just as
easily get sucked backward by the
current and drowned at sea I'll be
launched toward land and killed upon the
lava rocks landing on the kala Papa side
offered only slightly better prospects
an attempt required settled seas and
high tides in frequent conditions the
Kurd only from May to September the
remainder of the year storms complicated
the procedure although the peninsula
itself blocked the swells generated by
the easterly trade winds the villages
north west facing Shores foes to
Breakers thrown off by the Pacific's
winter storms
which sent 15-foot high waves rushing
toward land every few seconds a captain
might send off a loaded whale boat then
watched helplessly as a massive breaker
left to life snatched the craft knocked
its steersman from his berth and
splintered her on the rocks
to try and make land at either Shore
carried the looming possibility of loss
and a captain often would simply refuse
an attempt if he was impatient or
corrupt he might pitch his cargo
overboard and market as delivered one
Island skipper named William Sumner was
notorious for encouraging his passengers
to leap over the rails and swim for it
in time he would come to serve the
Molokai route
according to a letter Lewis Laporte
wrote On January 8th 1866 the Warwick
brought the first group of patients
around the collar pop aside on Saturday
morning January 6 then anchored a
quarter mile out while the crew ready to
whale boat boarding the small craft
required descending a loosely strung
contraption of rope and wood even for a
nimble sailor such a climb was risky to
a person made weak and clumsy by disease
it was terrifying
after the patients had boarded the
little boat several crew members climbed
in took up a set of long oars and
attempted to pilot her to shore in the
last day the warm weather had broken and
now driving rain swelled the sea an
audience of Kalaupapa residents watched
with interest as the whale boat was
flipped to land and spilled forth the
first X Isles the part met the patients
on shore to each he handed the items the
Board of Health had purchased for the
settlers then received a shovel or an
axe and a single gray wool blanket women
got only the blanket the Frenchman spoke
little a little Hawaiian and very poor
English struggling to make himself
understood the part is simple the small
party and began to march them toward Cal
awhile he rode horseback the patients
followed on foot one of them asked where
are the doctors
where is the hospital the part did not
answer the question
it took an hour to reach their
destination and with each step the air
grew bitter a dirt path ran between the
two villages crowded with rocks that had
tumbled from the cliffs after several
hundred yards the trail began to rise
and brambles closed in from the sides
squeezing the group into single-file a
mile along in the hike they reached the
near edge of the given grave when velu
across the empty mouth of the dead
volcano a low in constant moon on the
far side of the crater the carpet of
brush vanished in waist high grass and
the path curved toward the Mint's cliff
on the right
soon the trail topped a low bluff before
them lay an abandoned village and behind
it blue ocean a 20 foot high wall of
frozen black lava divided the two every
few seconds the sea rushed the rock was
startling violence that exploded into
glittering foam this was kala while the
patient's looked around six months had
passed since Rudolf Maier had fixed the
departure of the villages original
residents and storms had peeled roofs
from the cottages and burst once snug
brown grass huts the village appeared
haunted still midday it was already
becoming dark the part tried to explain
about the angle of the cliff in the long
shadow now creeping toward them the
patients would need to get quickly
settled find wood and put their fires in
place by this time however the Exile had
gone without sleep for more than 24
hours in the last day they had eaten
only a few scraps of bread and had
walked on damaged feet for more than two
miles the clothing advantages were
soaked from the sea voyage then made
filthy from the overland hike bone tired
sore and disoriented they sank to the
ground and slept the part climbed onto
his horse and rode away
and it was first day there he questioned
if people know about Molokai they tend
to know about it through Father Damien
who is probably the most famous resident
of it he arrived in the settlement seven
years into his exist into its existence
and in those first seven years it was
very much like a Wild West Town the
analogy was made that in indeed later
that it was more like the Lord of the
Flies
they were uncivilized people and
civilized people and they broke into
factions and they battled each other and
and there were innumerable murders and
rapes women were taken as sexual slaves
children were sold as slaves period but
over time it began to sort of divide
again and they they formed a small
government and and learned to sort of
sort of create a community not of things
the government was constantly in a state
of financial distress and they provided
very very little for the people there on
the island the original concept was that
they would become farmers and feed
themselves but most of them were either
too weak too angry or too bitter to
actually do any significant farming and
so they immediately fell into a state of
starvation that remained for 20 years or
so when the board first realized that
they weren't going to be self-sufficient
there is a scene in the book where the
headboard number stands up and complains
noisily what we have to feed these
people - by the time Damian got to the
colony the population was 742 and in
seven years they had never provided
regular medical assistance to anybody on
average people died once per day and
every several weeks more boats would
arrive and either throw people off the
side or bring them to land occasionally
they brought them in on the cliff face
but that was so sure that when they
tried to bring feed cattle down the
cattle would leap over the sides and
splatter on the rocks 3,000 feet below
so they stopped doing that part of it
Damian had volunteered to go to the
colony because the Catholic mission in
the islands had recognized that they
were at that time now 200 Catholics
and they didn't have a priest they
needed somebody to take confession and
to do baptisms and they were all so
fearful that the Protestants might slip
in there beforehand and get hold of
these 200 people so they set up this
plan where for missionary priests would
rotate each taking four months at the
time as I said they thought the disease
would rapidly contagious and so they
figured the less time a priest stayed
the less risk he would have of catching
it and so Damien was chosen to go first
and they sent him in and unexpectedly
for the church at least he proved to be
a huge public relations boon he became
immediately famous around the islands
for martyring himself but going in and
the and his superiors quickly recognized
that even when his first four months
were up they couldn't really take him
out because they would lose face with
the papers and so there is another scene
in there where where his superior is
talking to another man in the mission
and admits well I guess we're gonna have
to leave him there Damien was 33 when he
when he got into the colony and I will
read you another section his days began
before dawn when he woke said prayers
and ate a breakfast of boiled rice dried
biscuits and strong coffee then he
stepped out into the colony if someone
was dying he anointed them with the oil
of last rites and if someone had already
passed he slipped on the clean cassock
and performed the burial service during
a good week he might bury as few as
three people during the bad stretches
and it's cold and rain several died
every day when he had a spare moment
Damien would hurry to the hospital to
work alongside William Williamson Blaine
Wilson was a patient as well spinning
bandages dressing sores and passing out
medicine protea died of mercury 1/2
grains of opium potassium arsenide and
swigs of watered laudanum he took the
settlers confessions scolded them and
gave them praise he performed baptisms
played games with the children and
conducted lessons in carpentry he gave
detailed advice often unwanted about
gardens and crops in a state of an exile
home
he knelt with people in prayer so
frequently that the fabric at his knees
turned to tissue by the time his rounds
were finished Damien had circled on foot
for ten miles the cliff overshadowed the
colony and the early moon had risen in
the chalky light Damien would find his
way to a small rut white rectory he was
building and light a candle and then
began to write he pinned dutiful reports
to the mission house lists of the
supplies he needed snippets of sermons
and many letters home he spent at the
last of the guttering candle light
writing messages to himself in the
margins of the notebook things he wanted
to accomplish things he must remember to
do one evening not long after he landed
in the colony Damien scribbled festoon
Alinta
rushed slowly still no questions no good
bless you
actually the the isolation policy stayed
in place it was it was started by the
Hawaiian government which at that point
was a monarchy and the king was acting
on the advice of his American and
European advisers primarily this one
gentleman who was the leading physician
in the islands at the time and he
happened to be a backyard beekeeper and
he had noticed in his hives if one of
his bees got sick the other bees in the
colony would shove the bee the sick be
out and let it die outside so that
didn't infect all the rest and so he
watched this and then came into the
Board of Health meeting and said we need
to exile these people and that's what
they started to do it was yes and the
exile policy stayed in place after the
Hawaiian Islands were annexed by the
United States and even after it became a
state itself and up until 1969 when the
isolation policy was was repealed it was
in a book that I found filled with
irony's that was one of the great ones
and I make the I sort of play off of the
fact that it was the summer that that we
sent men to the moon to walk on the moon
that our own physicians and scientists
finally decided that we don't have to
imprison these people any longer this
was 20 odd years after they had found a
cure for the disease and and we're
readily treating it quite a bit the
business community desperately one of
the people hidden out of sight oh sure
you wanted to know what part dole and
he's referring to Sanford dole who was
the first president of the Republic of
Hawaii and then became well basically
the fact of governor when it became a
territory and he was one of the leading
in in in the islands what part he played
with the business interests and the
plantation owners in the exile policy
and the answer is that all of them
wanted the sufferers of the disease out
of place because they thought it would
drive down tourism and also by that time
there was the beginnings of of what
would become the canned pineapple
industry and as it happened the holding
area the small hospital where they
attempted to diagnose the disease or
held people until they exiled them
abutted the cannery operations and
people on the mainland assumed that
their cans of fruit were going to get
infected and so they had to move that
hospital and move the people off the
island the disease itself is just as
simple is a is a relatively simple
desert disease and it's caused by a
bacteria and if it's left untreated the
bacteria can cause disfigurement it
detects the skin and the nerves it
doesn't happen in every case but in some
cases it if it's left untreated it can
become what the myth of leprosy often
tells it's called Hance that's a modern
name for the disease because the word
leper has become such an epithet and
become charged with so much emotion that
the people who had the disease or still
have it
preferred to be knowed in Hansen's
disease sufferers in the book it was it
was it was difficult because I was
trying to find there is throughout the
book people want to go to this colony
because of the the grotesquerie the
thrill of the bizarre and the unknown
and the Board of Health was constantly
having to sort of tell tourists no you
can't come and yet they would often
often let in notable tourists like
Robert Louis Stevenson or Jack London or
whatnot and in writing the book I tried
to find this balance I made a decision
very early on that I wasn't going to try
and describe anybody with the disease
that the descriptions in the book all
come from somebody else's mouth either
come from physicians or some of these
visiting writers and and similarly I
struggled about how much how much of the
the truly grisly aspects of the disease
and really the horrible aspects of their
early days I should include on boat days
they called the days that that either
new patients arrived or the male's came
or sometimes they would get the meager
supplies that they called they call them
boat days and in the early period of the
colony all of the rebels all of the like
in a prison yard the most brutal and
cruel people form together in a gang and
they would terrorize all the rest of the
patients and the terror started from the
moment that you were put on that little
skiff I was talking about and pointed
towards land often these landings
occurred in in night or in the pre-dawn
hours and so the people who were most
disfigured and wanted to exploit that to
the greatest degree would take torches
and ringed the land ring the landing and
stand with the torches in front of them
cackling while these the new patients
came in and as soon as they got near
land they would start screaming in this
place there is no law so it was it was
quite horrific to try and go to go there
and and the the sentence of being exiled
was was considered by the government to
be a death sentence they they acted as
if he were civilly dead if you happen to
be married they granted your wife a
summary divorce and they executed your
will as if you were already in the grave
in some cases they took your your
savings to pay for your own exile the
first chapter of the book actually is a
flash forward sequence it takes place
about 20 years into the policy
and it concerns a young cowboy who who's
diagnosed with the disease and rather
than go to Molokai because the
reputation of it is so horrific by this
point he escapes into them into the
mountains of Kauai with his wife and
children and holds off a posse of
government soldiers for more than a
month and they never rousted him out of
there he ended up killing four soldiers
and a sheriff and he stayed up there and
died and his wife buried him in the
hills and then silently kind of crept
back out
I can read one more sure go ahead answer
ask it and I'll repeat it you know I'm
from Hawaii I was born there I went to
school there I went to the University
there I'm a graduate of the University
of all right well you know we hardly
heard anything about the lepers on
Molokai except for the people who who we
didn't even know that there were exile
sir forced to go to Molokai and live
there against their will
who are these exiles what kind of what
background did they have because Hawaii
is a place of many different ethnic
groups were they all Hawaiian no they
weren't they were you know they were as
representative as this audience is now
they were they were government agents
would go out and into places of work
offices or schools or homes if they
thought you had the disease they
arrested you and you were subject to do
a cursory exam in some cases that lasted
30 seconds and then you were you were
launched on on your way to exile and and
in time the colony came to include
people from almost every nation there
were Americans there Japanese Filipinos
Chinese Britons all over and from every
economic class in the beginning what
happened was I was really actually sort
of I don't I don't want to paint the
government out too
the villain in the book because they are
not much of this much of the missteps
they did they did because they didn't
know any better but in the beginning
they they sent out flyers and said if
you happen to suffer from these symptoms
come down we'll provide free medical
care for you and so you were you were to
report to this this hospital outside of
Honolulu and of course most of these
people who came initially were destitute
and they were poor farmers or tradesmen
or whatever and they got to the hospital
and they were diagnosed and the ones
they thought had the disease they were
locked in the hospital and held to go
into into exile and so eventually people
began to react not only to that
invitation but also any any appearance
of a government agent with terror and
they would run hide in the caves make
for the hills doctors were murdered
soldiers and policemen were shot because
they thought they were coming to take
them away and of the 27 people who
remained there most of them went is his
young children
and most of them had been there 50 60 70
years by the time the isolation policy
was repealed they had spent their entire
lives there and they either preferred it
as a place to live now because they were
among their friends or they had nowhere
else to go
yet another irony of course is that by
that time by the 1970s kala Popov is a
peninsula that I described at the
beginning as being very grim was by far
the most beautiful place in all of
Hawaii it's magnificent simply because
it started as a prison nobody could get
to it and despite the fact that for many
years developers wanted nothing more
than to get their hands on it and exile
the Exile is again and turned it to go
luxury spa in 1980 they turned it into a
National Historical Park and
uncontrolled access to it
so call the locals because you know if
there any anything like myself they
probably don't know hardly anything
about what took place in color Papa at
the leper colony sure and so did you did
you find that when you are doing your
research where did you get children well
you know the the sure she wanted to know
if I spoke to the locals when I was
reporting the book and where I got my
information and I did speak to some
locals and I did quite a number of
interviews in the settlement itself in
the community itself with the remaining
patients it depended it's a really ugly
chapter in American history and in
Hawaiian history and there's this this
sort of cross-purpose impulse to to bury
it and hide it and pretend it never
happened or to learn from the mistakes
unfortunately they don't tend to learn
from these mistakes in the 1980s again
when the AIDS crisis began coming up and
they were fearful of what this assumed
to be a highly contagious disease there
were discussions on a government level
of turning this into the National AIDS
colony and hasn't some resonance again
right now with avian flu people want to
know you know how we're gonna react to
that with quarantine or isolation
sake you know news to be everybody all
the things that had been going on there
yeah even during the time that you know
we were living there and I'm sure that
nobody that I know of that's there in
Hawaii that so-called locals know
they're hardly anything about you know
what yeah it's not it's not it's not
love wild widely hey they repealed the
law in 1969 at that point anybody who
was on the rolls and they may have been
in the hospital that they were
maintaining in Honolulu by that time or
they may have been members in the
community they had to choose where they
wanted to live did they want to stay in
Colorado or did they want to to go back
into Honolulu the last patient arrived
in 1969 arrived voluntarily however
though because he chose to spend out
there years there
sure it actually started changing
slightly in the in me in the early 1900s
about 1905 1910 as they began to learn a
little bit more about the disease and
they also finally found a competent
medical staff to stay there and live
there and you know it was it was quite a
lovely community they - when it started
to change by that time it had a social
hall it had a dance hall it had a roller
skating rink a movie theatre and two
small hospitals and bars and a cafe and
it was it was quite pleasant and they
hit they had started learning things
about the disease so that they could
alleviate some of the symptoms and make
life more pleasurable for the people who
had it and they also began to recognize
that not everybody got the disease and
so they started letting people go who
were either misdiagnosed or who had an
obvious form of the disease that wasn't
communicable but the the myths of the
place stayed so strong that the
government finally invited Jack London
to come in on as a kind of press junket
to report and tell the world that this
is this this nice little community and
so he came in and the bargain the board
struck with him was that he could he
could have free access to it and and
meet everybody had talked to everybody
but they they wanted him not to not to
paint a horrific picture of of the place
I think one of the patients asked him to
give us a good breeze Jack because they
had been so misunderstood and true to
his word his piece it was called the
lepers of molokai and Iran and ladies
woman's Home Companion I guess which is
the forerunner of cosmopolitan and it
was a very sensitive very accurate very
thrilling kind of piece at the beginning
of it he talks about sailing past the
island on his private yacht and
describing it as as the most cursed
place on earth this pit of hell but at
the end of it he said if he had to
choose between the Lower East Side and
Molokai he'd live in Molokai and so the
Board of Health was just thrilled about
this and they thought finally the
reputation is going to change but little
did they know that at the same time
London was working on a series of short
stories and in these short stories he
took he took what he had learned about
the disease and what happens to people
with disease and and sort of deployed it
for maximum effect and he wrote a series
of very grisly very sensational very
gruesome and wildly entertaining stories
about people with leprosy in Hawaii and
of course those became much more well
known than the nonfiction accountant and
the board was was very very upset with
that there's a couple of the doctors
continually tried to learn what they
could about the disease in any way
possible and and I write about a couple
of instances where where they are either
well-meaning or misguiding but they
decide to to use human soil is the
phrase they used to try and try and
learn about the disease to conduct
experiments and again I was talking
about the battle that I had sort of
determining how much to how much to put
in and how sort of upsetting or grisly
to get so these I've got to two passages
one's more grisly than the other which
do you want to hear
grisly more grisly but number two one or
two number two you're you're a brave
audience
this is a doctor who is in in the in the
settlement itself and he a doctor who's
working in Honolulu who's far more
brilliant than he is is having a little
bit of success and he becomes slightly
jealous and decides well I'm gonna you
know I'm gonna prove what I can do
the doctors name was dr. Arthur Moritz
across the channel on Molokai meanwhile
earnings work had inspired dr. Arthur
Moritz
although Moritz had no training in
bacteriology and lacked both earnings
moral approach to science and his
formidable intelligence he believed he
could find a cure at the time several
hundred Cocoa's resided in the
settlement Koch who is by the way we're
healthy relatives of patients who were
allowed in the beginning to go with them
and help them they the trade-off was
that they were treated exactly like the
x-files once they were there they had to
stay there and so typically what
happened
is a wife or a father or her son or
whatever would go along sacrifice
themselves to help their family member
Kokua means helper in Hawaiian do you
probably know that at the time several
hundred coke coolers resided in the
settlement these people offered a
splendid field for experimental work
Moritz wrote stretching all questions of
professional ethics I did not hesitate
to avail myself of the opportunities
afforded me for testing the anak you
ability of leprosy over the next month's
Moritz made more than 100 attempts to
induce leprosy in a healthy subject he
spent the bulk of his effort on ten men
and five women one cocuwa had arrived in
the settlement four years earlier to
care for his stricken wife Moritz carved
a pattern of incisions on the man's
forearm neck and navel then coated the
wounds with a serum brimming with
leprosy bacteria after the male after
the man be failed to become infected
morph sliced open his skin and dosed him
again using a thick needle several
inches long the doctor injected four
cubic centimeters of his quote leper
blister serum in quote into one test
subjects right buttock a month later he
injected the man a second time when the
disease fate still failed to appear and
irritated Moritz insisted the man
returned to his office regularly to be
coated with a pungent solve of bore
Aidid petroleum jelly and the blister
serum my favorite application in such
cases lawrence reported another subject
was a 31 year old man who had mistakenly
been exiled in early 1883 ten months
into his banishment the board reversed
its decision and released him but a few
months later wrongly exiled him a second
time when Moritz examined the man he
could find no bacteriological evidence
of the disease hoping to create it
Moritz repeatedly scored the man's skin
with a scalpel blade and then inoculated
him with lepers serum on a surface about
the size of a half dollar over each
lumbar region Moritz also experimented
on men and women who already had the
disease using corn plaster he fashioned
two-inch square boxes open on
side or it's then strapped the boxes to
the arms thighs and abdomens of his
patients and filled these tiny cages
with hundreds of blood sucking insects
fleas bed bugs spiders horse flies
mosquitoes the insects his notes record
were allowed many hours to feed
afterwards Moritz etherized the engorged
creatures immense their abdomens Nick's
the resulting pulp with alcohol and
centrifuge the solution spreading the
bull d the bloody paste on a pane of
glass he checked for leprosy bacillus he
found no trace to explore the
possibility of contagious leper breath
as he termed it Moritz constructed an
elaborate apparatus that fit atop the
patient's head with rods that projected
forward of the years he hung curtains of
antiseptic gauze from the rods covering
the subjects mouth for the first first
twenty such experiments Morris Moritz
instructed the patient to breathe
normally for several hours so that their
exhalations collected in the gauze like
do unto comatose patients he found in
the settlement Hospital Mort simply
taped the cloth across their mouths for
12 hours after removing fabric he sank
it in a solution of carbonized water let
it steep six hours then centrifuge the
liquid when he could find no bacilli he
repeated he repeated the process this
time ordering the patient's took off
continuously for hours on forty two
female patients Moritz conducted gynae
logical examinations to determine if the
disease might be sexually transmitted
male subjects were asked to urinate and
ejaculate and their issue was checked
for bacilli every week for more than a
year Moritz hosted his bizarre dinner
gatherings in the hospital dispensary
guests arrived to find the doctor had
prepared a feast of salt salmon mullet
and mackerel
all fish common to the Hawaiian diet
excuse me before serving Moritz took the
meal and reduced it to a paste then
tested the material for the bacillus
hee hee portioned the food out in
spoonfuls and instructed the patients to
chew for exactly two minutes and then
spit the pulp into a cup to be tested
next he served poi each guest was told
to plunge his fingers deep within his
mouth coat the digits with saliva then
bury them into the communal Bowl when
they had done this Moritz rushed in and
pulled samples from the bowl circling
the table the doctor thumbed open his
guests mouths and collected additional
samples to determine if bacilli traveled
freely from the nose to the mouth and
throat
mort's threaded long swabs through his
subjects posterior nasal passage
painfully forcing the object up the nose
and then maneuvering it down the back of
the throat before flight finally
plucking it out of the patient's
trembling mouth the experiment proved
nothing
although Moritz was able to state
conclusively the tears of the leper
contain no bacillus lepre you wanted the
grisly
the hospitals in you he wanted to he
wanted to know what agency sort of
administered the hospital I'm assuming
the board the Hawaiian Board of Health
did and when Hawaii became a territory
that turned in the Department of Health
and that's who administers it now the
colony itself by the way was was
overseen or supposedly overseen by two
people a absentee superintendent called
the basically superintendent who was
chosen because he happened to live at
the top of the cliff and could keep an
eye on whatever was going down there he
would visit once a month or so there was
also a resident superintendent I talked
about him at the beginning the first one
is the Frenchman Louis Laporte and that
man was supposed to maintain was
supposed to manage things day to day in
the beginning they tried to use
outsiders or non-hawaiians because they
thought Hawaiians wouldn't be able to or
capable of managing themselves but
eventually they found some competent
people to do it and again and about the
1905 a man named Jack McVeigh took over
and did it for the next 20 years and
proved to be you know a wonderful
manager yeah dr. Moritz was was hired by
the Board of Health
and actually very very well regarded
there is a and when they finally did in
the in the 1970s again in irony when
they finally did create a facility for
treating the disease they named one of
the buildings after yes if conditions
improved after the Sisters of Charity
which were the Franciscan nuns arrived
and started working there these were a
group of nuns from upstate New York
outside of Syracuse and they know that's
a different that's a different group and
there's they're kind of rivals but but
they arrived in the final year of
life after Damien passed away Damien
indeed actually caught the disease I
didn't talk about that he happened to be
one of the 5% that did not have a
immunity to the disease and he never
took any of the basic precautions and he
caught the disease and although leprosy
isn't fatal what happens is that you
tend to die of things that leprosy
engenders like pneumonia or liver or
kidney failure and he he spent 16 years
in the colony and died at age 49 his
last year five nuns came to sort of take
his place and the lead nun was a woman
named mother Marianne cope who was in
the news about six months ago because
she was beatified and she soon to be a
saint Damien is also soon to be a saint
the only place in America that has two
Saints that lived and died there she
stayed for 30 years and they they did
have they had a huge impact they were
one of the first groups in Hawaii that
actually understood germ theory and
understood about antiseptic sand and
disinfection and whatnot and they
immediately began applying those lessons
in the colony you know sure she asked
what the what the remaining residents
thought of the project and and when they
heard I was going to write write the
book
you know everybody treated me very very
kindly there there was one of the things
that I first started reading about
before I even went into the place for
the first time these these government
reports and letters from from patients
in the 1860s and 70s it became obvious
that people who entered the the colony
or as it's known now the community we're
all subject to to what might be called
the handshake test and as soon as
someone came in one of the residents
would come and greet them and offer
their hand and based upon your reaction
that would that determine how they were
going to treat you for the remainder of
the time that you were around if you
flinched or if you avoided
in the early days some doctors refused
to deal with the patients unless they
were wearing gloves and many of them
conducted their examinations with a
stick when they did come in to bring
medicine some of the early doctors would
simply pile the medicine outside the
gate and then run away again and so the
first time I came in you know I found
myself sort of subject to this as well
and by that time I had I knew enough
about the disease to know that everybody
down there had been on had been cured
had been on the drug regimen for a long
time and they posed no risk and and so I
their hands and had no problem I went
from there the myths of the disease are
so strong though the first time I hiked
in and it's a it's a 2 mile long climb
down 2,000 feet there's 26 switchbacks
and it's an extraordinarily beautiful
and extraordinarily sort of dangerous
Trek it's been made safer now so that
people can get in and a lot of people
take mules on a mule train like you're
at the Grand Canyon down but I hiked in
for the very first time and I had done
some pre reporting and I knew a little
bit about the disease and I knew about
the community and whatnot but i but the
myths of leprosy are so strong and
pervasive and that as you as you get
closer and closer to that moment where
you're going to have the handshake test
you find yourself increasingly nervous
and I had to sit not only from being
winded from the climb down but just to
sort of get hold of myself i sat down
and you know took a couple of breaths
and then and then crossed the final
bridge in the community where did the
research that was productive and led to
the cure come from
and what is it about the bacterium that
makes it it seem to be predominantly a
tropical or warm climate disease chest
we're the research that that led to a
cure came from and why the bacteria
seems to be a warmer tropical disease
I'll answer the second part first um
I'll I'll preface this by saying I'm not
a leprosy expert I'm not a doctor I
don't play one anywhere and the book is
the book is is not a history of the
disease so much as it is just a the
series of the people who were affected
by the disease it's a character driven
narrative of the place that said though
the disease is no respecter of latitude
or longitude it originates equally in
hot and warm climates and it used to be
endemic and in Norway in Minnesota all
sorts of the place what happens however
now is that people think it's a it's a
subtropical disease because where it
remains a problem you know are in poor
developing countries that don't have
whites bed spread access to to the drugs
that cure it and that tends to be Africa
and Asia Southeast Asia and areas like
that but it's still leprosy is is more
prevalent in the United States than
measles is there's still a large number
of cases that happen every year and
there's about seven thousand people in
the United States who either have or
have had the disease in the Bay Area
there's about 300 or so so that's the
first half the second part is the the
cure actually originated in the
treatment hospital at Carville Louisiana
which some people sort of talk about is
America's other leprosy colony it was
founded however more's as a center for
research and treatment and rather than
as a prison as as kala papa was one of
the chapters in the book concerns a guy
named John John early who ended up being
what might be called the first leprosy
activist and and he was a mountaineer
from North Carolina and really ornery
irascible guy and he had a very mild
case of the disease and yet he was
diagnosed with it while he was in
Washington DC
trying to get to collect his his
veterans benefits from the
spanish-american war and they seized him
and arrested him and put him in a tent
on the banks of the Potomac and put
armed guards around the tent to keep him
from escaping and the Washington Post
would file daily updates on on what was
happening with John early and I sent a
photographer out there's a book and
there's a picture of him in the book and
hundreds and thousands of people came
along this thing and to try and catch a
glimpse of this this man and the
soldiers would try and hold him back the
place where try and hold him back he he
had a habit of escaping wherever they
put him and he would time his escapes to
public policy debates in Congress and he
would inevitably appear in Washington
whenever they were debating public
health and barged into the halls of
Congress and scattered the congressmen
he got loose one time and this was on
his second or third escape and the
police said John early is coming again
and they mounted the largest manhunt in
the history of Washington DC
other than the Lincoln assassination and
he still got around them and showed up
in Congress and eventually it did a lot
of good because he managed to shake
loose the federal funding that led to
these elaborate laboratories and
scientific research at Carville and in
1942 1941 or 42 that's where they found
the cure a happy story it depends poor
and well some of the in Norway they they
had a much more enlightened approach and
they and they they recognize the disease
wasn't terribly contagious and so you
know they treated them just like they
treated somebody who happened to to have
tuberculosis they they gave them ample
care and and allowed them to if they
wanted to sort of recover at home or
horror or whatnot
others had equally harsh and in terrible
places Japan had some of the some of the
worst instance
of civil rights abuse and actually a
couple of years ago the government
finally admitted that they had treated
these people oftenly and they they paid
them 15 million dollars in reparations
anybody else know where there are a lot
of babies born in the colony and how are
those children treated there were there
were there were sure he wanted to know
if there were a lot of babies born in
the colony and in the early days there
there were there were children born to
patients to pairings of two patients or
two Cocoa's as I was talking about
people who didn't have the disease or
some combination of both and and they
the the issue of leaving healthy
children there was very troubling to the
government and to everybody else and so
they they would take them away within an
hour of birth and send them up the cliff
and and then put them into foster homes
after they had stayed at the hospital
for a while eventually and this is
another sort of dark chapter in the
history of this place they began
sterilizing the residents the patients
so that they couldn't have children and
this was during the the late 1920s and
early 30s when the eugenics movement was
was very popular in the United States
and and they made a condition that there
was a hospital in Honolulu that people
went to if their problems got very
severe and they would go and get taken
care of and then they were brought back
to the colony if they wanted to go to
this hospital in Honolulu to have their
medical needs taken care of or while
they were there they were allowed to
sort of see across a double fence they
were allowed to visit with their family
that might be in Honolulu and so people
wanted to go there very badly the
condition they made for going and
getting treatment or seeing your family
was that you had to be sterilized
I'm chaste if the if the remaining
residents had had talked about or been
successful in getting reparation they
talked about it a lot they have not
filed any any legal papers to do so and
most of the average age of the of the 27
remaining residents are is 27 all right
I'm sorry 72 years old and so they're
getting up there and right now I think
probably the best that they're going to
be able to expect is that that their
story gets known and and that that they
place that they had to go becomes this
Historical Park and is preserved in
their contribution to it is preserved
just wondering if there was at that time
any remnant of biblical belief that
leprosy was a punishment for sin he
wanted to know if there at that time who
was there any remnant of belief that
leprosy was a punishment for sin and
absolutely that's who actually would
drove most of the most of the early
early policy and everybody was laboring
under the assumption that it was in in
the hawaiian culture that stigma didn't
exist until the missionaries came and
used bibles to teach the locals how to
read and it was at that point that they
decided well okay well this disease
carries the stigma so we perhaps should
do something about it I mentioned the
book being filled with ironies this is
this is one of them the the people that
the Bible that the Old Testament
describes as lepers never had leprosy
the disease they have is not leprosy it
is it's thought to be any number of the
skin conditions that commonly are
mistaken for leprosy including psoriasis
and eczema and one and it also is simply
used as a umbrella term to describe
somebody who is who's falling out of
favor with God so that there's a social
stigma
and what happened is that that that
stigma attached itself mistakenly to
this idea of leprosy and that continued
through the through you know to modern
times to 1500 1600 1700s interestingly
enough at the same time non Christian
scholars knew exactly what the disease
leprosy was and they had a specific term
for it and they treated it simply as a
an unfortunate condition that somebody
had to endure but it wasn't any sort of
moral diagnosis and these two terms
existed the wood actually was the Arabic
term for the disease and in the
Christian term for the disease and when
in the in the 1500s a monk was making
the translation of the buff of the Bible
and and medical journals from Arabic
text that would serve as the text for
the Western world and he mistranslated
the word and all of the biblical stigma
got attached to the disease leprosy and
it went forward from there
so it was an editorial mistake that has
led to all of the stigma which is
something for copy editors in the
audience to think about Hawaiian term
for disease was called the separating
disease because separated the family so
it sounds like that term must have come
after the Christian missionaries and the
government policies towards the state
the disease so is there a Hawaiian term
for the disease that precedes the
Christian content she was asking about
the Hawaiian phrase for the disease and
it's it was actually known as a
separating the separating sickness and
whether it originated after the exile
policy and it did Hawaiians I I'm I talk
about this a little bit in the notes and
Hawaiians gave very literal descriptions
to their diseases one of their diseases
is called the squatting sickness and
it's actually dysentery and so any they
did apply the separating sickness and
also the sickness that is a crime
the to the disease they also mistakenly
thought that it had all been brought in
by the Chinese and so they called it the
Chinese sickness I can't answer that one
I haven't really I'm not familiar with
that practice Hawaiians did have a it
actually it was only last year that that
scientists discovered the genetic quirk
that makes you susceptible to the
disease and they had long thought that
it followed along either racial or
familial lines and Hawaiians were
slightly more susceptible to the disease
than than others French people were
slightly more susceptible to the
diseases in others that's why Louisiana
happens to be a locus of some of the
disease because the Acadians came down
from Canton French Canada
anything else
other locations were
it was aggravated
in the United States oh sure
all over the world they were mushy asked
if there were other if there were other
places that people with the disease were
segregated were sent away and many
countries maintained leprosy colonies
and in the early days many towns many
communities in the United States had
small ones in Massachusetts there was an
island off the Cape called up and
nothing pronounce it correctly but it's
called pinna Keyes Island and that's
where they sent people they were is
actually they were going to turn Angel
Island into a leprosy colony and
Congressman wanted to turn one of the
Aleutian Islands into a leprosy colony
as well anybody else you know I we're
sort of concentrating a little bit on
the grisly and their horrific they the
book is actually is actually quite
inspiring what happens is is that over
time the strength of these people's
faith and spirit conquers everything and
by the time you get to them to the
modern age you've got this amazing
loving community of people who have
overcome everything and indeed turned
into that survival story that I set out
to write thank you for coming out
John Taemin is author of the colony the
harrowing true story of the Exile of
Molokai for more information on the
island of Molokai visit Molokai Hawaii